I'd say the biggest problem facing New
York and any part of the United States
in the world is the dysfunction of the
family every time there's a
dysfunctional family it bleeds into the
schools into the streets and everything
that we have to do with other human
beings so if a person is dysfunctional
in the home what do you think all of a
sudden on the job they're functional oh
all of a sudden they snap to it when
they go to school when all of a sudden
they're hanging out in the mall they're
not trying to prey on you like they're
trying to prey on even their brothers or
sisters or the so-called uncle who
serves as a wannabe father from time to
time though of course the dysfunction is
what paralyzes society it means people
learn less they can't function properly
they can't speak they can't communicate
they have anger management problems they
develop necessities and desires to have
drugs and alcohol itself Medicaid and
they put you on a one-way trip to
Palookaville and we're always trying to
cosmetically make excuses for it but in
reality we turn our teachers into social
workers they barely have enough time to
teach you reading writing arithmetic and
the most important are respect and we
turn our cops into social workers
because we're not doing the social work
at home where it needs to be done from
the Jump Street
training people to be parents right we
train you how to drive a car we train
you how to shoot we say hey don't get it
gonna let you practice you practice and
everything you do practice playing the
piano practice singing practice swing
karaoke drunk as a skunk as you are you
realize boy I really stunk out the joint
I'm not a very good karaoke singer I got
a practice so you practice practice you
know Americans dancing with felons
whatever everyone's practicing and
practicing everything in a life that's
not important but the most important
thing parenting whether you wanted the
kid or it was an act of an accident or
you had that urge to merge and all of a
sudden the condom with paui and now all
of a sudden you have this treasure
that's been delivered and instead of
nourishing that treasure you want to
bury it somewhere out of sight out of
mind so I think really teaching
parenting skills is when babies are
having babies I mean it's over so under
the Curtis sliwa draconian measures boy
when I make a good minister of defending
virtue against all the vices you
wouldn't be able to get married in my
society until you were 30 I'd put you in
a gulag if you dare got married before
30 I think the furniture was upstairs
and rearranged in the wrong rooms and if
you decided to have kids I'm gonna test
you first I'm gonna say wait a second I
want to test your parenting skills I'm
gonna give you a kid from an orphanage
or what would we call it a a place in
which children are unwanted and you're
gonna have to take care of that kid
first and try to raise that kid and then
I would say at that particular time you
have qualified to have your own child
now that's a bitch Rako nyan wouldn't
you say but you know something you won't
have all of the unwanted kids that are
populating this world I mean you know we
go to bed at night and we live a pretty
damn good life but think of all those
kids out there be raped abused sent to
work at the age of six no life
whatsoever we know what's going on and
we don't do jack diddly squat to stop it
and all we see is machines out there
human beings on two legs pray with
procreating fornicating and copulating
as if they're baboons in the middle of a
forest hey I thought we're Yuman beings
I thought the strongest muscle that we
have
between both our ears that's what we
should exercise not everything that's
below our navel and that's all we seem
to do fornicate copulate morning noon
enough no oh I have a baby Maury Maury
Povich give me a DNA test
hey this is old dispatch
domestic situations it always is the
mama drama the daddy baby drama the mama
baby drama you're out there in the
street
some Gabon some shad rule some muscle
head is pounding some female into
submission and so you figure like oh
this is my time to shine now I'm gonna
be like the knight right who runs to the
rescue of the damsel in distress except
the moment you jump on the back of this
predator this violated and you take him
down for the count and he's forced to
submit until the police arrive then all
of a sudden the victim starts accusing
you of violating her rights his rights
the neighborhood gets all fired up they
come out in support of this violator and
now you gotta suck it up
you know you got to take the verbal
abuse the physical intimidation and
oftentimes the family the extended
family will attack you as if somehow you
have reached in to the epicenter of
their family and whip the heart and soul
out of their family this person who has
become a prime-time predator is now put
up on a pedestal so those are really the
most difficult situations that I have
ever faced and I know the guardian
angels around the world I've ever faced
because no matter how much good you do
is still wrong and when the police
arrived they look at you and they said
huh involved in what is that mama baby
trauma daddy baby drama mama drama okay
how you gonna work your way out of this
pile